ladies and gentlemen sometimes what ends
up being a scam may have started with
good intentions
and it's hard to pull a part of the
threads of where malice meets
incompetence but today
that's what we're gonna try to do and i
want to know your opinion what do you
think
was space odyssey the video game which
we're talking about today to talk about
the five signs five stages of uh
crowdfunding scams
do you think this was intended as a scam
did it become a scam somewhere down the
road it's hard to know
but the interesting thing now that we're
doing gofundme garbage this series by
the way welcome back
um the interesting thing is that you are
i do find
that sometimes i see a project and i
think oh this might not seem like a scam
to the founder
but they're just so incompetent that it
is a scam for the people who back it
like they will never get the thing
it will have to become something else
they're backing a project that cannot
exist
but the hubris of the founder or maybe
the incompetence
causes that then there's a whole other
category which is like no
this person intended from the start for
this to be a scam
so i'm telling you guys from the outset
i don't know which of these
space odyssey started as it seems to
start have started as may
like some people thought it was legit
because they got neil degrasse tyson on
board
uh but this brings us to the first step
because now we're going back in time
noodle grass tyson is heavily associated
with this project
it raised three hundred thousand dollars
to date has delivered absolutely
zero but the first step of any great
you know gofundme garbage is the first
stage which is
optimism ladies and gentlemen what could
be better
than a gofundme but
with nothing but promises but but
it inevitably crashes but let's get into
the hope
of this project here's neil backing
space odyssey the video game a
physics-based bass sim
we're thinking of releasing a game a
video game provisional name for it is
space odyssey
is that clever space odyssey barrier
i was trying to explore i'm teaming up
with the video game producers
can we think about a journey you might
take
where you control the formation of solar
systems
or planets of comets you you control the
formation of life
i mean honestly sounds great right like
that does sound wonderful
apparently three hundred thousand
dollars which was the goal 314 000
is enough to bring together a fully real
physics engine
that can create galaxies and give you a
beta tester and
full game download guys complete with a
hype
trailer the goal was easily met
how did we get here
how did it all start
where's han zimmer these are questions
that restless thinkers have tackled
over the millennia
kepler and galileo copernicus
isaac newton allow me to introduce to
you all
the next generation of exploration that
we call
the space odyssey
wow i'm hyped what if the games you play
could teach you the science of the
universe i can't make any sense
wait stop absolutely not okay
i'm sorry this was an unintended rip on
this
stop trying to make video games
education
and stop trying to make education video
games spatial geometry
will never be space invaders i'm sorry
i'm so
sick of this thing where it's like hey
guys this is done by all the pop science
guys they go hey
we can make science just as fun as video
games
no out of that what if education could
be as exciting as online gaming
this is like i hate
by the way not because i don't admire
the ambition but because i
what i the problem i think is that it
teaches kids that like
you should expect education to be
entertaining and my point is that it's
not
so why do we keep loading kids with that
expectation stop pushing this like
thing of like it's gonna be just as
great as your you know call of duty as
fortnite fortnite building
or advanced calculus it's gonna be the
same
explore and to create their own worlds
and
turn it into a game suppose i gave you
the power
to make solar systems and to make
planets this is a key thing with stage
one
it's about a lot of supposes suppose
this suppose that
but unfortunately they're taking real
people's money
for the supposes right part of the fund
of space odyssey
are the missions these don't exist these
are challenges they'll allow you to
learn but also
to really explore this is one of the
things i also hate about these gofundme
pitches
you can sell something that doesn't
exist thinking you're like oh what are
the
things about our missions it's like wait
do you have a mission system
no okay then what are you doing space
odyssey in a single sentence
the universe simulated for three hundred
thousand dollars oh and then tack on
neil degrasse tyson's name on it
so you ensure that people believe it's
like an actual thing this is what you
call
you know using famous people's names to
launder your
scam to people it's a really common
thing and unfortunately the person it
hurts the most is the popular person
who gets used this way so stage two what
is that we have optimism stage two is
delays
and frustration now after the initial
hype
it's funded the money is gone it
vanishes into the black box
of the founders wallets now is the time
where they actually have to execute
and here's where the rubber meets the
road and usually things spin
wildly out of control initially there's
always a lot of updates though as you
can see we're still in 2017 we've seen a
lot of updates here fully funded fully
funded yes exciting
but over time well you start getting
posts like this
we realize we haven't been giving
regular updates on the game
oh really and then the updates
which first maybe seem like oh it's just
the founders hard at work
get well they just get uh well these
breaks just get longer and longer
between each update a hallmark of each
of these new posts
is apologies for not updating and then
doubling down and saying we're gonna
constantly update you from now on
but it never happens and this is where
we move quickly into
stage three hatred this is when backers
first show signs of
turning on the project comments about
refunds start cropping up comments about
two full months no updates this is
beyond ridiculous at this point
three months since last update now
beyond ridiculous hope at least i will
get refund good luck
it's been what now four months after
this car kickstarter i'm gonna have to
make a rule
for myself not to back video games on
kickstarter
people start complaining blaming
themselves blaming the project
and it starts to get really desperate
people start also driving home the
original
estimated delivery date of august 2018
and meanwhile nothing's been done a year
later now here the project has two
options they do one of two things they
either go to stage four or they skip
directly to stage five but
stage four for most projects they go to
stage four which is
goal post shifting we saw this with the
unibrush
where they went from like a super
advanced swedish danish design
toothbrush to like the thing from hell
uh yeah that's what they did here as
well goal post shifting is where you
basically say yeah the things we
promised
we didn't actually promise those from
the get-go and actually we're going to
try to deliver
something but not what we said we were
going to deliver
in this case they start complaining that
uh the initial funds they raised well
those were only initial fees see it was
just
a starting point it was all a goof guys
really when they said they were going to
get you a beta test for your money they
didn't mean that
because actually once all expenses
agency expenses marketing art creation
and production and fulfillment of the
books posters etc
were sent out as uh and re rewards were
deducted
there was not a lot remaining on the
development guys they didn't have money
for development
because they spent too much money on
other dumb stuff apparently
and this is the goal post shifting part
the intention of the crowdfunding
campaign was not to create a game
no it was actually to introduce the
vision of the game to the community and
seed
early development did you expect to get
a game for this no clearly they didn't
mean that we will need to continue to
secure
additional funding beyond the campaign
a game of this magnitude needless to say
requires significant capital
to build so guys it was a goof when they
said 314 000
will build this for you really it was to
judge initial
interest and it turns out you guys were
pretty interested
this is so beyond shameless now one
hilarious thing here
is that they say don't worry guys they
apparently created a
special for their supporters with the
nasa store now remember everyone's
excited about neil degrasse tyson
mr spaceman so they partner with
nasastore.com we can offer you
30 in credit on the site while they're
going to give you free money
well only if you order 75 or more aka
like 30 off what complete garbage
what is this that's not giving i hate
when they say hey we give you 30
credit if you first spend 200 you go
ahead and give me money
you send me 100 i'll send you 20 bucks
back that's the kind of credit i want to
give you
how stupid is that anyway you get very
cool nasa and space
stuff so you go so i went to this
website you know wanting to look into
this because i was like really it's
called nasa space store
and the domain is dead so you know me i
gotta look into it well it turns out
when you do some way back machines of
this
store it seems to be like some knockoff
nasa merchandise
and apparently they were like using um
the logo or something
possibly without permission because it
changed from nasa store
to now it's called mission control store
see mission control store was formerly
called
nasastore.com so let's get this straight
neil degrasse tyson
partnered with a video game company
which promised immersive realistic
physics engines for three hundred
thousand dollars they didn't do that so
they said
hey go spend a lot of money on a fake
nasa store
what who why how is this like hey
i got you a great deal a bomber jacket
for
97 at this point it looks like another
cash grab from these people we don't
know if they're a partner with them or
what but of course this brings us into
stage five of the crowdfunding life
cycle
of a scam stage five is abandoned
minimize and move on this is where the
crowdfunding project basically gives
their last
or what will probably be their last
update so here we're seeing that their
last post
which was april 11 2020 so they've
totally abandoned this project but
they go like we understand the
frustration we share it
blah blah blah like a complex video game
with real physics is costly
and though we've not secured all of the
funding to complete the game we are
coordinating with a number of strong
prospective
financial and strategic partners that's
probably a complete
lie uh there's absolutely no evidence of
that and it's probably just more
minimization to keep people
strung along while they basically run
away with the money but that's basically
it guys those are the five stages and if
you want to run your own scam
that's how you do it courtesy a la
coffeezilla
that's the way to go i hope you've
enjoyed this episode this trip down
memory lane
to neil degrasse tyson's failed
kickstarter but also
an inside look at how these kickstarters
fall apart so quickly
thanks for watching hope you had a good
one and i'll see you guys tomorrow up
and smell the coffee